tesla enthusiasts may be eagerly
anticipating the first cyber trucks or
semis to roll off the assembly line but
according to elon musk there is
something even more important coming
down the pike it's hard to imagine that
a company known for electric vehicles
could one day be more famous for a robot
this i think
has the potential to be
more significant than the vehicle
business over time so why on earth would
musk make such a bold statement because
he sees the potential the market for
labor is much bigger than the market for
cars the 45 trillion dollar global labor
market is 16 times bigger than the
global car and manufacturing market
estimated to be about 3 trillion
optimus came as a surprise during
tesla's artificial intelligence event in
august except they used a dancing human
in a robot suit to show it off since
there wasn't and still isn't a prototype
some media outlets dismissed the tesla
bot as a joke at the time but if you ask
musk he's serious about it tesla bot
will be real
musk said it makes sense to develop
robots because it already has the best
and brightest engineers working on
similar technology for its cars teslas
are learning how to navigate the world
using cameras and neural networks just
like the electric vehicles the robot
would use the autopilot's cameras to see
and be equipped with a full self-driving
computer instead of a face it'll have a
screen but other than that it resembles
an average sized human at five foot
eight and 125 pounds initially the tesla
bot is meant to help out with everyday
tasks it should be able to you know
please you know please go to the store
and get me the following groceries musk
anticipates the robot will also be used
in tesla's factories if we can't find a
use for it then we shouldn't expect that
others would the first use of the of the
tesla optimus robot would be at tesla
kind of like moving parts around the
factory or something like that that
seems like a simple task however as the
technology improves robots have the
potential to eliminate all boring and
repetitive jobs they're already frying
in some restaurants and one day could do
dangerous work like exploring mines
inspecting water pipes and could be
employed in fulfillment centers as
e-commerce continues to grow and who
knows they could even help spacex build
the city on mars
robots are highly productive they don't
take breaks they work all the time and
they don't get paid for those worried
about losing their jobs robots could
help solve the labor shortage hitting
the us hard to such a point that
mcdonald's has to cut back their hours
at thousands of stores nearly 9 million
americans called in sick in january due
to omicron exacerbating problems already
caused by last year's great resignation
where people quit their jobs at
unprecedented levels what happens when
there is uh
no shortage of labor
some predict we could get to the point
where humans won't even have to work
unless they really wanted to
billionaires like musk richard branson
and mark zuckerberg are backing a
universal basic income for citizens
tesla has been beefing up its ai team
significantly the head of the division
andre carpathi is hiring deep learning
software engineers to help leverage
their expertise beyond their vehicle
fleet but what about musk's own declared
fear of robots he's warned of scary
outcomes like the terminator potentially
wiping out human civilization
he once commented on a viral video of a
boston dynamics robot performing parkour
by tweeting in a few years that bot will
move so fast you'll need a strobe light
to see it sweet dreams perhaps musk
figures it's better to build robots his
way than have someone else build them
their way when youtuber and investor
dave lee surmised musk is taking matters
into his own hands to quote save
humanity from evil ai robots he got a
like from the tesla ceo musk may have
had this in mind for years in 2015 he
co-founded the non-profit research firm
open ai he later left its board to avoid
conflicts of interest with tesla openai
has the explicit goal of ensuring
artificial general intelligence benefits
all of humanity artificial general
intelligence is different from
artificial intelligence ai is capable of
the tasks it's been trained to do an agi
system can do almost anything humans can
do without any oversight from us in
other words it is truly intelligent we
haven't yet achieved artificial general
intelligence some question whether this
is even possible but when a computer
beats the best chess player in the world
or the best alpha go player in the world
and when deep neural networks can detect
a person's sexual orientation by
studying their face the ai research
community believes the exponential
advancement of ai could culminate into
agi
to prevent a terminator-like scenario
musk has stressed he plans on
decentralizing the control of tesla bots
in its current form the robot appears
less intimidating than the ones created
by hollywood and it's intended to be
friendly of course
we're setting it such that it is um at a
mechanical level at a physical level uh
you can run away from it
and and most likely overpower it musk
has said optimus could be in production
by the end of 2023 and previously stated
a prototype could be unveiled in 2022
although deadlines are not his strong
suit
tesla is also juggling plenty on its
plate production of the cyber truck has
been delayed until 2023 and must
confirmed the company is not currently
working on a less expensive 25 000 car
it had previously mentioned just like
cars the difficulty lies not only in
building robots but in mass producing
them it could be years before the bot
becomes a core part of tesla's business
let alone overtake sales and vehicles
there is one sector a humanoid robot
won't overtake
driving instead musk is betting on robo
taxis a network of fully autonomous
teslas that don't even need a steering
wheel regardless of whether it's a robot
or a robo taxi robotics in one form or
another will be driving tesla's future
some of the best engineering mines in
the world at tesla are working to solve
complex problems if you're inspired to
learn new skills and make an impact my
sponsor skillshare is perfect for you to
try out skillshare is an online
community with thousands of classes on
anything you're curious about whether
you'd like to learn how to edit videos
how to create animations or graphic
design for myself the class with
polymatter was really helpful in
understanding how to make beautiful
graphics down to color choice the
classes are broken up into short
sections and there are no tests or ads
the first 1000 people to use my custom
link in the description will get a one
month free trial of skillshare
thanks for watching for newsthink i'm
cindy palm